Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is Bonnie Tsui.
She is the author of a really beautiful new book
called "Why We Swim".
I loved it.
This is a conversation about swimming of course.
It's about human beings' relationship to the water
through survival and community and flow.
And speaking of flow, this conversation does just that.
I really enjoyed it.
Hope you do too.
So hit that subscribe button
and please enjoy my conversation with Bonnie Tsui.
So nice to meet you.
Thank you for doing this.
It's such a pleasure.
I'm so glad to meet you.
I appreciate you coming down from Northern California
and I'm so glad that you jumped in the ocean today.
Like I said before we started
I would have been
horribly disappointed
You'll be disappointed
right, I had to.
If you didn't go swimming
before our conversation about swimming.
It was one of those,
you know, really beautiful sunrises.
I mean, you kind of get jaded living down here I think
in California specifically.
Jaded?
Jaded.
And I paddled out this morning and took a photo
and I sent it to a friend who lives here
and he said
I think we talked about it sort of like
maybe puncturing his like, jaded heart. (laughing)
Even his, after being out here, he could
enjoy it.
Well there's a lot
of reasons to complain about Los Angeles
but the beaches and the weather is not one of them.
Yeah, it's not bad.
You know when I hear you talking about surfing
at Ocean Beach,
like I used to live in San Francisco.
I'm like, oh my God.
So cold and like unforgiving and uninviting
on some level compared to
what you could do in here.
It is a battle.
It's a battle to get out.
That's part of the thing, right?
Mhmm.
It's like, I think about it.
I like to think about it as making a date
to like go wrestling with the ocean in the morning.
And I expect it right,
at OB, you always expect that it's going to be
somewhat hellacious even on a easy, low,
you know, baby day.
But I kinda like that.
I kind of like being challenged
and I partly am okay with it
because my surf buddy Caroline Paul
she is one of the first,
she was one of the first female firefighters
in San Francisco.
So she's just like this,
you know, she's a pilot, she's just tough.
And she has basically had like nine,
10, 11, 12 lives of adventure.
And she will go out
and look, stand on the beach, looking out.
And every time she goes,
"It doesn't look that bad."
Every time, no matter what.
It could be, you know overhead, double overhead.
And she'll just say, "It doesn't look that bad."
And then, so we'll go, we'll try it, you know?
We'll be repelled back.
We'll be, you know, booted out of the whitewater.
But I think just like
having that mindset is a good way to be.
And I like that about
Kind of gets easier the more you do it,
but it never quite gets easy enough.
Like the number of times,
I couldn't count the number of times I've stood on
an outdoor pool deck in ridiculously cold weather
staring at the pool, knowing that the water in the pool
is warmer than the water in the air
and still being unable to like
jump in that moment where you're just staring at it going
"How am I going to get into this water?"
It's breaking the seal, right?
You know, it's still the membrane.
It's like an invisible membrane between you.
Right.
And it, and yet,
I think that it takes something,
it takes some activation energy
to break that seal every time, no matter what.
But it's always worth it, right?
Yeah, always.
You're never like, "Oh, I wish I hadn't done that."
Yeah.
Are the pools still all closed up north?
They are, they've started to reopen.
So my local pool, the Albany Aquatic Center,
sort of just North of me and Berkeley,
that's sort of my home pool.
It didn't reopen until very recently.
A month, two months.
And so I just ended up swimming in the Bay
for the last eight months or surfing.
Didn't they close Aquatic Park also?
They did.
Yeah, they did because I think too many people
were going there in the beginning.
And then they closed the Dolphin Club
and the South End Rowing Club, the facilities.
So even now, you know,
I have friends who-
I mean that seems liek pretty low risk.
But I think in the beginning it seemed
just the flat.
We didn't know enough.
Right, right, right.
So there's the flocking together.
But now we know of course,
being outside great, you know?
In the water ocean breezes, great.
Like keep doing it, survive, get through this, you know?
There's a couple of pools that are opened down here
but they've all migrated to these online platforms
where you have to reserve a lane.
You have to make, yeah.
You've been doing that, right?
I have, but every time I look at,
I log in and everything's booked.
Yeah it's like zero, zero, zero.
I never know.
Like, I just like to go.
I'm like, "Oh, I got, I got an open hour.
I'm going to go do it."
Like, it's difficult for me to know day to day.
So the other week I like booked a lane
every single day at different times throughout the day.
And I didn't make it once cause there
was some intervening.
Oh, no.
You just were throwing a bunch of things on the wall.
Yeah, cause it's a long drive actually from my house too.
And it's just, you know,
I'm struggling with that.
I did the exact same thing that you just did this morning.
Cause they opened up and I said,
"I'm just gonna, this one's open, this one's open.
I'll just, you know, snatch it and see."
Grab them, yeah.
Sometimes I show up without a reservation
just to see if somebody doesn't show up
because I've missed so many.
I assume people are having the same issue.
Any luck?
I'm hit or miss with that.
Anyway.
I'm so glad to talk to you
about my very favorite subject, swimming,
and the human relationship with water.
And this book that you created
is just a beautiful work of art.
It must be incredibly gratifying
to have it be so well received.
I mean, making the Time 100 Must Read Books of 2020.
I mean, that's incredible.
That's pretty special.
It was.
As a writer,
somebody who's been writing for a very long time,
that's quite the accolade.
Yeah, you know, I of course
I've been thinking about this book for many years
before I decided to write it
and figure out how to frame such a big topic.
Right, swimming is as a topic.
It's not a book.
It's not a story.
It's not a narrative.
And I had to provide that and I had to figure out
how to do that in a way that felt right to me.
And to see it finally out in the world,
and of course I could never have imagined
that it would come out into the world
during a time when most people
actually couldn't go swimming.
Right.
Was just very strange.
And then of course the, you know, over the months
I mean it came out in April, the hardcover
and then it came sort of rolled out
around the world in the summer,
and then the paperback will come out this coming April.
But to have then the gift of those months
where people were thinking
about their relationship to swimming
in a way that they always had,
they'd always taken it for granted.
They'd never interrogated why it made them feel good.
They would just show up at the pool, you know,
do their workout, see their friends and go home.
Basically did not enter their minds
because we didn't have to do things
like make lane reservations, you know, two weeks out
to get some time with the water.
And to get these,
I've gotten the most incredible letters from people.
I would never have thought that
the book would get people to swim in open water.
I didn't have any specific intentions.
There's no agenda.
There's no agenda, exactly.
It was meant to be this,
you know, this cultural and scientific exploration
of our human relationship with water
and with swimming
and how it's so curious that we,
we as a species are not born knowing how to swim.
We have to be taught.
That's a very interesting thing about us humans
and about, you know, higher order primates.
Right, you make the point that we're the only land mammal
that doesn't instinctively know how to swim already.
And I'd never really thought about that.
Once I started to look into this and I,
you know in the book, I list examples of,
you know, dogs, cats.
Cats hate water, but they can swim.
Right.
Bats can swim.
That's a trip.
Bats can do
a crazy like butterfly.
It's insane.
Really?
Yeah, look, after we finish talking, please Google.
Some YouTube rabbit hole.
Bats swimming.
(both laughing)
So we have this,
we came from the water, but we're not suited to it anymore.
So we have to start,
we've been kind of clawing our way back to it
as land animals.
And part of it is of course survival
but also it is so much more than that.
Once you learn how to survive the water
it can be so many things.
And that sort of how I laid out the book, you know,
the question is presented in title, why we swim.
And then it's structured in these five thematic ways
we can answer that question.
And I wanted to get at all of that
because I want it to be this expansive
and really inviting,
an invitation to come in the water and look at it.
I took it to be very
like sort of a swimming version
of Chris McDougall's born to run.
I've joked with him about it.
That was my goal, yeah.
There's a little bit of Murakami.
You know, what I think about when I think about running,
it's like a swimming version of that.
Wow, thank you.
The born to run thing,
with the born to run thing, though
it would have been great
if you found some undiscovered
indigenous tribe somewhere, super swimmers.
That'd be too, you know,
too much the nail on the head, right?
Right, but it has that vibe.
It has that feel to it.
And you know, I'm somebody
who's passionate about the water
and somebody who's had a, you know
on a personal level, had a relationship to swimming
from as long back as I can remember
and I've thought deeply about it.
And I've written, you know, snippets about it over time.
I wrote my college essay
about what it feels like to be like underwater, you know?
Like this is something
I've been thinking about for a long time,
but never thought about what that might look like
in an expanded, you know, comprehensive version.
And you captured it perfectly,
like it's the perfect book that fires on all cylinders.
And it is this weird,
Thank you.
Like when you telescope up
and look at humanity's relationship to water over time
like there's an anthropological kind of aspect to your book.
There's this push pull
like we're drawn to the water, you know,
coastal, you know, real estate is expensive for a reason.
There's something about being by the water
that appeals to us on a very profound level.
And we're also terrified of it and repelled by it.
So it's that tension that makes it interesting.
I really wanted to get at that.
I mean, I wanted it to be a book that was not
just for swimmers, but for people who didn't,
don't call themselves that,
don't think of them selves that way.
And why is that?
It's because of this tension that you speak of
between life and death, you know,
immersion, submersion, flotation,
like this, this kind of
I talk about it in the book,
this porousness between states
that I think is like,
it's what's so enigmatic about the water
and so alluring,
and that we want, you know
we see of this gorgeous sparkling body of water.
We want to get in it.
I mean, kids, you look at babies
like they just are just in the bathtub, you know.
They're just enamored with it
because it's, it is not of us.
It's not for us necessarily, you know.
We need water to survive.
We need it obviously.
But when we see it around us, in our environment
there's just something that is talking to us
on a very essential level.
And I wanted to explore that a bit.
So what do you make of that?
Like, what is that, do you think?
Well, I was really interested to,
you know, in the course of my research,
discover that our brain activity changes
with the sound of water, seeing water, you know.
We know about how we respond to greenspaces, right.
We as humans just,
there are set points in the environment that we respond to.
I think there's a great book
by Florence Williams called "The Nature Fix".
And she talks about how
we are evolutionarily suited to respond
to certain set points in the environment.
And that makes sense, right?
So we, you know ,
being in the forest, being by the water.
And so we have always known this on some level, right?
So the books and, you know,
philosophers and writers and poets,
since time immemorial have all spoken about,
Right.
You talked about the Greeks.
Yeah!
You know, the water cure.
The samurai
which we're going to get into.
Right.
And so once you start looking
you realize it's everywhere.
It's everywhere, across time.
And so I was very interested to know
and wanted to learn a little bit more about the science
that's starting to catch up to explain why that is.
You know, how our bodies respond,
not just, you know, physiologically, with immersion
and with the mammalian dive reflex and all that.
But that just being near water, not even getting in it
looking at it, walking by it, smelling it,
listening to it,
that our brain activity or our alpha waves increase
and that's, that's calm, relaxation, creativity.
I mean, that's good stuff.
And we know that to be true.
Yeah.
It's no mistake that images of sunsets at beach,
beaches are on meditation apps.
And, you know, there's something about the gestalt
of the waves crashing and the light bouncing off the surface
and the smell too
that produces this calming effect
that can't be replicated in other environments.
And I just know, personally, when you swim,
as somebody who runs and rides bikes and does
all different kinds of things,
there's something unique about swimming,
the experience of that and how you feel in the aftermath
of it that is very different
and unique and special.
What do you think it is when you think about it?
I think there's something about the submersion
and the muting of the sound
or the sound of what the waves
you know, what that does in your ear canal.
And the sort of suspension of gravity
and the loss of feet.
Like you, you lose your sensation of your limbs
in the same way that you have on land.
Like all of those things combined to create this
you know, very different experience that I think is
you know, healing to the human body and mind.
Flotation weightlessness, an unburdening
I think is really what happens physically
and mentally, emotionally, I think.
You know, you can't help but respond
to the medium in that way, I think.
And there have been times,
I mean there are, you know,
the swimming in my life has changed over time.
I mean, it has played different roles.
But especially over the last year,
I think about getting a water as such relief,
like so profound from this
fire hose barrage of badness in the world, you know.
I think just to have a momentary
pause from that, a relief from that is just,
you know, it is, so it's such a gift
because it's so easy to do
and yet not everyone does it.
Not everyone thinks to do it.
And it's kind of the last frontier,
if you want to get away from the phone
and all the signals,
Exactly, yeah.
and noise and the stimuli.
I thought about that a lot.
And it changes your perception
and your relationship with time.
Mhmm, yeah.
It's uncomfortable if you haven't done it before
because you're like, wait, you know,
I need to listen to music
or I need to, you know, like I'm not comfortable
with not being overstimulated.
And you kind of have to like, let that go.
You are left alone with your own thoughts in a way.
Right, how terrifying.
It's like the worst, right?
Why would I do that?
Why would I do that when I have airpods?
Now there's like these devices
where you can get underwater audio
and they're figuring that out
and I'm like, I don't want it.
I don't want any part of that.
I need to protect this place as the one place
where I get away from all of that.
I think about, you know
they've had sort of somewhat crappy technology
to do that for some time.
It doesn't work so well.
Exactly, and there's a reason why you don't see people
using them very often.
I mean, by and large, I mean, I would say like
in a pool at any given day
98% of the people are not using anything like that.
Right, I hope it stays that way.
I know, I do too.
Well, let's take it back to the beginning.
I mean, you know the obvious question is like,
why write this book?
From whence comes your deep appreciation
and love of the water?
I mean, I got to go back to my parents, right?
By now I've talked about this story so many times
but maybe you haven't heard it.
I've heard it.
But people listening might not have heard it.
So this is the book tour.
You answer these questions,
This is the book tour
that I have never had.
We'll go in a different
direction, but I like this story.
So go ahead.
It's a really good story.
My parents met in a swimming pool on Hong Kong
and that's our family origin story.
When we were kids growing up and heading to the pool
for swimming lessons and my parents would be there.
And then over the years we joined the swim team
and we became lifeguards.
People who came to know us laughed when we told them
that our parents had met in a swimming pool,
because it was just, it was too perfect.
Of course they did.
Right, yeah, there's that black and white photo
of your parents.
They were quite young when they met.
They were.
I think they were, I asked my mom recently
and I think they were 18, 19, something like that.
I mean, they're just gorgeous.
I mean, they just have the hots for each other.
You know, I just want to
freeze them.
It's all happening.
Cause I see them
and I hate to say this, but I have never seen them so happy.
This beautiful, you know, unfiltered.
I mean, both of their smiles are so big, you know.
And it is a memory that I never had myself.
But I look at it and I like to think of that
as a time when they were really happy, you know.
so my dad was a lifeguard and my mom was at the pool.
But when we grew up
they were always at the pool with us or at Jones beach.
And we would go in the summers and spending time together.
It's just very much baked into
my brother and my experience of our nuclear family.
Because until I was
I guess in junior high, early high school,
our parents were together ostensibly.
And then they, my father started kind of, they separated
but we didn't really know it as such.
And so he started traveling back to Hong Kong
and then to China, he's an artist.
He won an Emmy.
He won an Emmy, yeah, he won an Emmy.
You know, he and I were so close when I was a kid.
And I was the one who accompanied him on trips.
I grew up in New York, on long Island, mostly.
And I would go with them to client trips
into Manhattan and we'd go to the Met.
And we would just,
I would spend hours with him in his studio.
We were very close.
And so I associate,
you were telling me about
you wrote your college essay about swimming.
I wrote my college essay about swimming and art and writing
and those things were,
now that I think about it,
they still are me.
I knew from a young age that those three things
were so essential to who I was.
Actually, I was visiting my mom this summer
back in New York,
and she made me clean out the garage
and I found my college essay.
And I thought,
it's very strange to be looking back at this person
and understanding what stayed the same.
Many things stayed the same, you know.
Essentially this relationship I have with the water
and also with writing and creativity,
that's something that I trace back to my dad.
Like very much so.
Yeah.
He was the permissive free spirit.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, he was fun and he was a kid
and he's today, at 73 years old, he's still a kid.
He actually hasn't changed that much
but I have, you know.
Was your mom more of the task master then?
Oh, totally.
She was the strict one.
I don't actually remember her smiling.
It's terrible.
It's so terrible.
But, you know, after they divorced
which was really, really painful,
they didn't finalize their divorce until I was in college.
But then I got to know my mom as this, as who she was.
She was a person who was not in relationship to my dad.
She was fun.
She had her own ideas.
She had stories to tell.
That's when I got to know her, you know, as a real person.
You need both of those.
You know?
I think you need the artistic sensibility
but you need the regimented person as well.
Oh yeah.
You know, she was the one who said, you know,
my desire for order, my desire to prepare,
like all of those things come from her.
Like my sort of risk averse (laughing)
older person self is because of her.
And I say those things lovingly.
And because I understand that those are things that
you need to operate
and be a responsible human in this world.
And I take the fun and the creativity
and the light from my dad.
But I also know that in the context of our family,
that really ruined our family,
this sort of shirking of responsibility
and not owning up to that.
So profoundly both parents
have shaped me to be who I am.
Yeah, you came out pretty good.
Oh, thanks!
So it worked out, you know.
It could have gone
terribly wrong.
You go to Harvard, right?
And yet you're an artist.
So you have, you know how to focus
and, you know, organize your life
but you can also be a free spirit and creative
and you know, follow these whimsical
passions that you have to track down these stories.
Yeah.
My mom, I remember my mom said to a good friend of mine
this was when I was 22.
and I took off for a few months to go
on a fellowship to New Zealand.
And I was, came back and I had student loans to pay off.
And I said, I really want to work
at this adventure magazine.
You know, they're not paying me right now
but I just, I'll just you know,
take a waitressing job or something in New York
while I'm doing it.
And she said, she turned to my friend and she said
Bonnie is such a free spirit.
And she, it was not a compliment.
Right.
But you know what, though, to her credit
like a couple of weeks later, she said,
you know if you really want to do this,
I will support you in this.
And I did, I did it for six months.
And then I got a job that paid money, actual money.
And there we go.
That was probably a big step for her.
It was.
Actually, now that I think about it,
it really was.
I have to ask her about it if she remembers.
But you grew up in and around pools all the time,
swam competitively, you and your brother.
But you didn't end up swimming in college, right.
You rode crew in college.
No.
Yeah, by the time I got to college
and I wasn't good enough to swim in college,
like not, no.
But I was done with competitive swimming
because college, to me represented like something new,
like something super fun and exciting.
And I always knew that I was going to,
college was going to be in the place where I got
to meet new people and do new things.
And I very much felt that I wanted to do that.
Cause I wasn't, you know,
I think I was a very old person when I was like a kid.
You know, I was like, I want to be 20.
And I am eight, (laughing) something like that.
I get it.
I just wanted to have autonomy, I think.
And I rode crew.
You know it's so quintessential
it's almost a cliche to be like rowing.
Sculling in the
Charles river.
At an Ivy League college.
Yeah.
It's like the Ivy is like, you know.
Within sight as you're on the water.
Still a water sport though.
It is, I wanted,
and I was talking to a friend about this recently.
I just thought it was so cool
to have a different perspective of water.
And when, you know, when you're swimming
it's so solo, right?
You're on a team, but the experience of swimming
is very much you in the water.
And when you're in a boat with, you know
seven other people
and you have to become one,
you have to move in unison almost all of the time.
I would say like 98% of the time,
you can feel like the slight tug of someone else
who's not quite in your sync.
And then the 2% of the time when you are flying together
it's just so magical.
It's like, it's as if you are taking flight
and you didn't even, you're not trying.
And I was thinking this the other day, because I wanted
I really loved experiencing water
from a different perspective.
And then I only quit because
you know, you're looking at me and I'm not a giant person.
You know, I'm probably between like a coxswain size
and a lightweight river size.
You're not small enough to be a coxswain.
I was not, I'm only 5'4.
I was like,
the coach said to me, "Your technique is great.
I put you in stroke in this boat, you know
but you have to put on like 20 pounds."
And I had already packed on, like
I was eating like a crazy person, you know
in the freshman dining hall.
I was working out in the weight room,
I was erging like a maniac.
And I just was like, I think I have maxed out.
I don't know that I can gain any more weight to do this.
It was weird.
So you were like, I'm done?
Well then I joined water polo.
Oh, you did? Okay.
Again, another water sport.
Yeah.
But it was fun.
I mean, it was hard.
I just realized that after awhile that
as playing a sport in college
and you know this more than anyone is,
that's all you're doing.
Yeah.
It's pretty all encompassing.
And I didn't want that.
You wanted to broaden your
aperture, your horizons.
Yeah, yeah.
Totally.
Yeah, I get it.
What's interesting about your relationship
to swimming in high school
is that the pool represented
like this refuge for you, right?
Like you had a complicated relationship
with your peers in school, but at the pool,
which was a much more diverse
you know, it was literally a pool
of all different kinds of people.
It was kind of like a refuge,
like a place where you felt at home.
And I think that's worth exploring a little bit.
And I really liked how you did
this kind of archeological dig into the history
of the United States
and its relationship with swimming
and in particular you know, pool building
and access to pools and how that changed over time.
So let's talk about that a little bit.
Cause I think it's pretty interesting.
I know, like I grew up in the Northeast.
And you know, most high schools don't have pools
whereas in other parts of the country they do.
And that tracks back to our, you know,
sort of checkered relationship with race and segregation.
I really did not appreciate,
meaning I didn't understand
the extent to which
the current, you know, gap, the racial gap
in swimming ability between especially blacks and whites
in this country is so traced back
to this era of segregation in our country.
And the fact that it persists to the degree that it does,
I mean, I think the rate is that
the latest statistics show
that black kids are five times.
They drown at a rate five times that of white children.
Right.
I mean, that is just , it's horrible.
And then it's not just swimming access and education,
but it's also then when you break through to join a team
you find a team you're swimming, you love it.
And then you feel like you're the only one.
You know, swimming remains a very white sport.
And you don't feel welcome
or you don't feel that you belong
or that you have positive images and stories.
I think that that has a really profound effect
on whether you want to keep doing something, you know?
So like I recently got to talk to
the founders of an organization called Black Can Swim.
And Ebony Roseman is the founder.
And she was talking about how
when her daughter started swimming,
and then I think the reason
that they started the organization
was because when they Googled like black kids swim,
they would come up with,
the top Google hits were like
black people can't swim or black kids
don't know how to swim.
Well, when I was growing up as a kid
there was this trope like,
oh, well, you know black kids can't swim
or they have a higher body density or something like that.
Like some crazy reason why
black people weren't good at swimming.
Which is just ridiculous.
And then that is pervasive and it persists.
And those are the ridiculous things
that I heard growing up too.
At the same time,
I think of my experience, you know,
as you pointed to
was really special for me, because I grew up,
I swam on a team that was in the next town over
and it was a very diverse community.
Freeport, New York is, you know
has a large African-American and Latino demographic.
And it also, the team also attracted kids
from all across Long Island.
And, you know, even though I was one of the,
you know "the onlys" in my high school,
a town away two towns away,
that pool was super diverse.
You know, the head guard, at that pool where I lifeguarded
at Freeport Rec was, was black, you know?
And she, I don't know,
I think to see,
my point is to be able to see representation around you
is no small thing.
I really credit that experience with,
I mean making me who I am today.
The section in the book
where you talk about this era
in the 1910s and early 1920s
when America was building these massive public pools, right.
We've all seen pictures of that extraordinary pool
in San Francisco that just looked like the
size of a mall.
Fleishhacker pool.
It was like the massive,
I think there was one in Chicago, too.
There were a couple of these gigantic
glass ceiling, you know,
like they look like arboretums almost
that were gigantic
that went the way of the Dodo, right?
Like they just disappeared.
Yeah.
So this was a shift in public pools from being,
you know during the progressive era,
there were pools for like,
before that was public hygiene, you know
like they were actually bathing facilities.
So like working class and immigrants would go.
And men would go on alternating days with, from women.
And so it was much more a gender split
with these pools.
And then once they became what you described,
these like pool palaces, basically,
like pools, then public pools where then for a recreation.
And so then were for families
and were then,
you know, public authorities, you know,
that the sentiment was that
people of color could not swim in these pools
with white people.
And so they were turned away from a lot of pools.
You know, and then during the civil rights era
the public, the pool spaces, the watery spaces,
even public beaches, that they were sites of protest.
And in the book, I talk about how
there was this incident called Bloody Sunday.
It was like in, on a public beach in Mississippi.
And it's where blacks went to be, you know
to use this public beach.
And there, you know, there were riots
and many of these pools that happened there was violence.
And if you think about it
we were talking about how water is freedom.
Water is relief.
Water is so universal to all of us as humans.
And yet this essential thing was not available to everyone.
And I think the right of leisure,
the right of recreation was something that was seen
as symbolic of this fight for equal rights and equity.
Yeah, and so ultimately these pool palaces closed down.
They just shuttered, right?
And then hence begins this movement
towards the backyard pool.
So that the public pool kind of
you know, isn't a primary focus anymore
because it's complicated for those reasons.
After desegregation, you know,
you'd think that the fight is over, you know.
Equality won, but actually
a lot of whites then, you know, of means
then fled the public community pools
and you know, built their own backyard pools.
And you'll see this,
you know in California, it's interesting, right?
Because California, especially Southern California
is such a an epicenter for this backyard pool culture.
And it's this beautiful.
I mean, you look at these photos
with like Palm Springs and LA.
it is this very golden light, perfect visual history.
And yet, where are the black people?
You know, where are the people of color in these records?
And I think that that is being rewritten and pushed at.
And you know that beautiful bubble is being punctured
in a way that, it's starting to be,
and in a way that is really important to our understanding
of what those images actually meant.
It meant exclusion, right?
It feels like there's still some way to go though
because the country is littered
with these public works pools that are all over the place,
many of which sit drained and empty.
Like that pool in Central Park at the North end of the park,
that massive pool.
Like most of the time, there's no water in that pool.
Like there seems to be a lot of establishments like that
all over the place that either
because they lacked funding or for whatever reason
that I'm unfamiliar with
they just don't, they're not really, you know,
they're like in disrepair.
It's really expensive to maintain a pool.
And what I learned in this pandemic period,
I was reporting a story
about a reopening of a public pool in my neighborhood.
And I learned that most municipal pools, you know
the public pools that are run by cities
operate at a deficit, even in normal times.
So they're hemorrhaging money.
And that the season in which they would take in revenue
is the summer.
You know, camps and like swimming lessons and swim teams.
And for this entire year
they did not have any of that.
And so now they're even more in the hole.
And so now, as many pools have struggled to reopen
in some limited fashion, right.
So, but think about it, it's one lane
per person spaced out.
If they were losing money before,
now it's a disaster.
I hate to think about
what it means, because
the sad fact is a lot of these pools
will not reopen, you know, even after the pandemic.
And so that to me is,
I mean, it's hard to stomach
because that means then another generation
of kids might not get what we had, you know?
And that's just really, it's hard.
I think about, you know,
in the course of researching this book
I learned that swimming education is universal.
It's part of the public school education
in so many other countries.
And I think that would be amazing
if that were the case in this country.
It would make such a difference.
But you need adequate pool access to do that.
And most schools don't have pools
or don't have a pool that's proximate enough
or as accessible.
It just comes.
It's a really huge funding issue.
But I just think about these, you know, in Iceland
you know, every town has a pool.
Every town!
I know.
Tiny, tiny town of like a hundred people has a pool.
Well let's talk about Iceland.
Because this is a big part of the book.
It's super fascinating.
I mean, first of all, we should mention
you said at the outset that you broke the book up
into these various sections.
Survival, well-being, community, competition and flow
which kind of cracked the code for you
and helped you figure out a way in.
Like how do you write a book about swimming?
It's just like this etherial amorphous thing, right?
But kind of planting your flag in these various categories
provided you with like some footing to do this.
A big part of the book or the early part of the book
is about Iceland.
And in particular, this one fisherman whose name
there's no way I'm going to be able to pronounce.
But I'd never heard of this guy before.
And it's an unbelievable story.
I will tell you about Guðlaugur Friðþórsson.
How long did it take you to figure
out how to let that roll off your tongue with ease?
It's it's been some time, many years.
Say it one more time.
Guðlaugur Friðþórsson.
But the thing that we have to know
is that his nickname is Loye
and everyone calls him that.
So I will
Loye.
henceforth, very good call him Loye
because that's way easier.
So I opened the book with a story
because how could I not, right?
It's a story that my husband told me one night
and he'd heard it from,
you know he works in with fisheries
and the environment and oceans.
And I think he'd heard it from an Icelandic friend.
And this story is famous in Iceland
because in 1984 there was a fishing vessel that capsized
off the coast of Iceland.
And Guðlaugur Friðþórsson, Loye was the ship's mate.
And he was like, he was 22.
He was super young.
The fishing trawl caught on the sea bottom.
And then, and then it overturned
and everyone got thrown over board.
And everyone's in the water holding on to the boats keel
before it starts sinking.
And you know, this is bad news.
It's 41 degrees water.
It's freezing, it's the middle of the night.
And they are, you know
they are unable to deploy the life raft.
And the sad thing about it is that
they were supposed to, the self deploying life rafts
had become a sort of thing fairly recently at that time.
And they were supposed to have installed that in the boat
but they hadn't done it yet.
So this boat is sinking and the, you know
the few of them that are left are holding onto the keel.
And then they say, you know
we're going to start swimming, Captain and Loye.
And so they start swimming
and pretty soon he's the only one left.
Was there a lighthouse?
Like, how were they
finding their, okay.
There's a lighthouse.
But it's six, at least six kilometers away.
It's the lighthouse on this island
which is off the coast of the main island of Iceland.
It's called Heimaey.
And it's part of the Vestmannaeyjar archipelago.
I've been practicing how to say that.
You got that down.
The Westman islands.
So he saw the lighthouse
the light from the lighthouse, and he started swimming.
And he's just swimming, swimming, swimming.
And he's wearing like a flannel shirt and jeans.
You, know, and a sweater.
Right, that part confuses me.
Cause I would just take that off.
That's holding you back.
I think he took his sweater off.
I can't remember what the,
I mean he certainly lost his boots.
But he swimming and,
you know he's talking to seagulls.
And it takes them six hours.
Six hours, six kilometers, and he gets to shore.
Now, the thing to understand about this island
is that it is a volcanic Island, like the fall of Iceland.
And I think it was 10 years before that
there was a volcanic eruption that had resulted in like
the island got bigger by like 20%.
But then there were also these like sheer
a hundred foot cliffs and like very spiky lava fields.
So he gets washed ashore
at the base of one of these hundred foot cliffs.
So he gets there and he cannot get out.
There's no way for him to climb.
So he has to get back in and start swimming.
So he swims around to a place
where he can finally get out and he's walking
across this lava field.
And he's you know, his feet are bleeding
cause it's really sharp.
Like there's a frozen, a sheep cistern.
It's like a tub of water that feeds, waters the animals.
And he like punches through cause he's so thirsty.
You know, he's been out there for hours and hours
and then he trudges into town.
And you know I think day's breaking
and there's like a light on the first house.
And he like walks up to the house
and there's like bloody footprints behind him in the snow.
And it is just insane because then they're like
I cannot, you know, they rush him to the hospital.
They can't discern his like heartbeat.
I mean, it's like very faint and his,
or it's like they can't really read his body temperature
but he has no signs of hypothermia.
So like you and I,
Yeah, that's crazy.
20 minutes max.
Yeah 41 degree water.
We would be dead.
Almost everybody would die.
And then how long was the trudge into town
as he got there?
I really don't.
I don't even know if he knows.
He must be delirious.
What was the air temperature?
I can't remember what the air temperature was
but it was significantly colder than that.
He's just a little dehydrated.
He's fine.
And they keep him in the hospital for observation.
And it's not for some time when they have done some
research and studies that he's taken part in,
but he has this, the reason he was able to survive.
Okay, A he's a very good swimmer.
Everyone in Iceland swims.
He was trained to be as such as a sailor.
And he has, he's like a seal.
His fat is two to three times normal human thickness.
It kept his core body temperature stable.
Was he a fat dude?
He's a big guy.
He's 6'4.
I don't know how much he weighs.
But at that, you know, you can see photos of him from that.
He's not unusually gigantic,
but he's a solid guy.
But you think about plenty of guys who are really big
who would die very quickly in, you know, water that cold.
It's not about the fat
but certainly the quality of the fat.
Right, the quality or where is the fat subcutaneous
in the right places to protect the organs.
Yeah.
It's crazy, right?
So he becomes this massive hero
and also a science project for a lot of people.
And he gets so much media attention
that it kind of compels them to become this recluse.
That's right.
And so you can imagine that
when I came across the story, I thought this is,
I got to talk to this guy because it just is so compelling.
And I know that he doesn't,
you know he's told this story before,
but has been a really long time
since he talked to journalists.
But of course the first thing you find
when you Google him is that this happened to him.
And then also that he doesn't talk to any journalists.
What soured him on the whole thing?
He told me,
it just, he felt that his story was being misrepresented.
And of course he started to feel harassed, right.
So like his friends died.
Yeah.
It's a horrible tragedy.
He's being celebrated
for something that's quite tragic.
Yeah, and I think at a certain point
you just want to live your life.
You just want everyone to leave you alone.
And it kept kind of coming up and coming up.
And to be honest though, I mean,
I want to point out that he was very vocal
in the first years after the accident
because the conversation they had on the boat's keel
was like, and he told me this later on was
if someone makes it, they have to tell.
And he said, you know,
nine times out of 10,
actually 9.9 times out of 10, nobody survives this.
And so they don't know what happened.
And he said, "I was the person who could tell."
And so he was advocating
he spent quite some time advocating
for the mandatory, yeah.
The lifeboat thing.
The self-floating life rafts.
And, you know, they have the swim every year
in his honor for like, you know, the last 35
six, seven odd years
called Gudlaugsund which means Guðlaugur's swim.
And it's everyone, it started out
as something that the navigation college did,
you know all the sailors did with their clothes on too.
But in a pool, right?
In a pool, absolutely, yeah.
Cause everyone would die.
That was the point, right?
You can't have that.
I know they breed them strong in Iceland.
Yeah, very hardy people.
They're not that crazy.
But it's interesting because he became
the symbol of Icelandic resilience, right?
They embraced him and that story and the,
you know, honoring him with the tradition of the swim,
because to Icelanders as a people
this is what,
he's like the epic symbol
of their survival resilience, you know?
And so he accepted that mantle.
But then after a while, just, you know,
It was hard for me to figure out then
how can I approach him in a way that's,
Right, how are you going to engender trust
from this guy who's been burned by the media
and wants to be left alone?
Right.
And you being the dutiful journalist,
you played the long game.
I played the long game.
Well, there was a movie I guess,
not too long after I found out about his story
there was a movie by this
like blockbuster Icelandic director.
Kormákur I think is his last name, Baltasar Kormákur.
He like did some Everest movies, I think
with like Denzel Washington.
Oh really?
Or Mark Walberg and Denzel,
I know he's directed that these like big blockbuster movies
but being Icelandic
he was obsessed with the story of Guðlaugur Friðþórsson.
I guess he was a teenager when this happened
and he said, "you know, this to me is the story.
This is like the adventure story.
It's like, what does it mean to be
a person in the speck in the sea
and what drives someone?"
Right.
And so they approached, the producers approached
Loye about the film
and he was just like, you know,
I think at this point he was,
he had kind of things had quieted down.
He was starting to live a life that was more to his speed.
Now he has grandkids, he has kids.
He still works in a fishing, for a fishing company.
And he was just like,
make the movie when I'm dead.
Like, I don't want any part of this.
But they made the movie.
They made it anyway.
Right.
So he felt betrayed.
He felt betrayed.
You know, he lives in a very small town
on a very small Island in a very small country.
You know everyone knows him.
The town, you know, protects him.
So I was just like, okay, how do I,
how do I follow my
you know, sort of storytelling instincts?
And also I respect this person as a human.
I respect his desire for privacy.
What if I write him a letter?
So I wrote him a letter.
I wrote him a letter
and then I ran it through a Google translate into Icelandic.
And then I mailed it.
You did?
But you can't pitch, right?
So what's the just, you know, I appreciate you.
Like, what is the letter?
I think I said,
I think I told him that I was working
on a book about swimming
and I knew about his story
and that I would love to just talk to him
about what swimming means to him.
I wanted to hear from him in some way, right?
So he wrote back almost immediately,
but he said no.
Right.
And then I thought,
"Oh, that's so disappointing."
But then we started to have this like pen pal relationship.
And I remember my husband had said,
like you could just write him
and see what happens, you know?
Because there's something about his opening message to me
that seemed to leave the door open a little bit.
He just said something about, you know,
I have not had great experiences
in the past with journalists.
It has nothing to do with your project.
But he said something in the email
and I'm trying to remember what it was.
Like, if you, the the message being sort of
if you can prove to me that you're trustworthy.
Not in so many words, but yeah, I got the sense.
So I just kept writing.
And I would send him, you know little bits of trivia
or when I was in Japan, you know doing some research,
I would send him a photo from there.
And because he, I think he said that he,
he said something about swimming, saving lives.
And he used emoji. (laughing)
I thought would he use emoji
if he wasn't leaving the door open a little bit?
I don't know, it was interesting.
Yeah, so I just persisted.
And then I didn't meet him in person until a year later.
And I still like to the day that we actually met in person
I did not know if he was actually going to see me.
Right.
But you'd go out to Iceland.
I go to Iceland.
You ended up getting an audience with him.
And the guy ends up being like your buddy.
He is this wonderful, funny.
He loves jokes, storytelling.
Like, he's just a very
endearing guy.
And he actually, you know,
we got to the point where
he trusted me with his story.
And then he very quickly,
you know he had an interest in my family
and we went.
Oh my God now it seems so long ago.
The summer of last year, 2019
we went to the Faroe islands
and we went to Iceland to see him.
And, you know,
he and his wife being very experienced grandparents
like they just had all these snacks
on the table for my kids.
You know, they just and my kids adored them
because they were just like
can we go visit Loye and Maria again?
Again and again and again?
I mean yesterday my son told me,
he said, "can we go back there?"
And, you know, on Christmas, you know,
he sends me a text with a photo.
Cause he looks like Hemingway
crossed with Santa Claus now.
That's kind of exactly how I would envision him.
He sent a photo of himself in a Santa suit and said
"I think this guy says he knows Felix and Teddy." (laughing)
I mean, it was hilarious.
Like, he's a great guy.
That's cool.
But what did he tell me?
I mean, he told me his story,
but also I what I realized is that
so much of what his story means
is what other people say about him,
what he means to them.
So I tried to do this kind of twinning effect
of like telling both stories at the same time.
Because it is about the stories we tell ourselves.
Yeah.
And on some level it's his story
but it's the national story.
Right.
And he's got to release that
and allow people to have their own experience
with who he is and what he endured.
Yeah.
I think that's right.
But this kind of opens the book up to this, you know
kind of dialogue about not just human survival
in the elements and in water,
but also the unique properties of cold water
and human exposure to cold water.
And we talk about brown fat,
like converting the white fat to the brown fat
and all the new studies that are
going on right now about
how cold water exposure extends longevity
and is healing to the body.
Right.
One of the studies that I looked at showed, okay,
so, you know, warm water versus cold water, right?
So I think it was like an hour immersion
in 90 degree water is like very comfortable,
very relaxing, you know, reduction in pain.
And you're just like, you're very,
it has positive effects on your body.
And same amount of time in like
56 degree water or something like that.
It was like dopamine levels through the roof,
like metabolism revved up,
like feelings of euphoria, you know.
I mean it is, you know,
and just like very alive wellness kind of,
you know, things that are measurable
but also things that you experience that are very acute.
Reduction in inflammation of course.
And I just think it's so interesting,
the way it speeds up our metabolism,
it's actually like on its face,
cold exposure is not that great for you, right.
So like cardiovascularly, it's like terrible.
It just like jacks up your blood pressure
very quickly at first.
And then over time, actually,
it lowers your blood pressure because it's just
your heart and your blood vessels are then
able to handle it.
Over time within a single session
or with repeated exposure?
With repeated exposures, yeah.
So, you know, we talk about
where the the sort of longevity scientists I talked to,
Hiro Tanaka, he was talking about how he went to Japan,
back to Japan where he's from
and he studied the Ama, right.
So those free diving,
grandmas, really like, you know.
Pearl divers.
The pearl divers.
You know, diving for shellfish.
And they, a lifetime of cold water exposure, right.
Their cardiovascular,
their cardiovascular health is amazing.
Their hearing is terrible
because the cold water really destroys your hearing.
He wanted to know about the
you know, they're like, how were their arteries, you know.
Were they flexible or had the, you know,
was their experience over times?
Had that made them something a little bit
more akin to Marine mammal, you know,
just like how they're able to,
you know, cope with the water.
And he found that they were.
Their cardiovascular health was really great.
And, you know,
I think they lived to be quite old, you know.
And the traditions, I think that there's been
renewed interest in just again like these people
who hew to thousand year old traditions
and are able to do things that we wouldn't imagine doing
you know, in our modern day.
And they're not dying of heart disease.
Right.
And that, Hiro Tanaka also did research
with arthritis, you know, and cold water and swimming.
And what I was really interested in was that
the swimming practice lessen the effects of arthritis.
And, you know, from a pain perspective
from an inflammation standpoint
from a mobility, increased mobility,
and those effects lasted for much more time
beyond the actual time in the water.
And so it's just like
the benefits are enduring.
And I found that really compelling.
Yeah, that's super interesting.
Yeah.
So you're way into this cold water world
quickly becomes our mutual friend, Kim Chambers.
That's right.
Who's a looming figure throughout the book.
Like she's, you know, other than yourself,
like almost the primary protagonist throughout this.
I mean, how could she not be?
I know.
Well, she's larger than life.
I mean, she's just, I just, I love her so much.
And I just think the world of her, she's amazing.
But she brings you down to the Dolphin Club
and introduces you to the whole aquatic park.
The whole crew, exactly.
That's exactly what it is, it's an ecosystem.
Explain what that is.
I used to live around the corner from there.
You did?
I never, I mean, I've swam in aquatic park many times
and I've swum from Alcatraz and all of that
but I was never like a member of the Dolphin Club.
I only know a few of those people.
I know Vito and
a couple of other people, but.
Yup, yup, yup.
I mean, so the Dolphin Club and the South End Rowing Club,
they've been around since the late 1800s.
They share an actual building, you know
but their courthouses, yeah.
They're kind of rivals.
Yeah they're rivals, but they're friendly rivals.
And they love to trash talk.
And, they are very much,
the members are like die hard Bay swimmers,
cold water swimmers.
Most of them,
you know, take pride in the fact
that they don't use wetsuits,
do it year around and have this,
I mean, there is a celebration of like the hardiness,
the vigor, you know, how long to stay in and, you know.
Not cool to go and swim at aquatic park in a wetsuit.
Well, you can, do you know what-
You can, but.
The first time I did it
I was afraid. (laughing)
Oh, that's cute, right?
I was afraid I was going to get ridiculed
but you know people were very nice to me.
But they just said you can't bring your wetsuits
into the clubhouse.
Yeah they said, leave it outside.
I'm like, okay.
It's almost like,
you know, when the wetsuit, like
there's a line it's like a no passage
through the space, no wetsuit shall enter the space.
And it's all ages, like all body types.
It is amazing to me that,
that there's this community there.
It still amazes me and I've seen it
and it's just beautiful.
And so Kim, you know Kim's the first woman to swim
from the Farallon to San Francisco.
She is a sixth person to do the ocean seven.
And she did all of this after almost,
I mean, I think all of your listeners
will probably be familiar with her story
but that she almost lost her leg to amputation
after this accident where she fell down the stairs.
And she, it took her two years to relearn how to walk.
She was embarrassed about her scars
and part of the rehab was like, you know,
maybe swim, you know?
And she, by her own description was a horrible swimmer.
When she started had horrible technique.
And then one day she's invited by a couple of guys
at the pool to swim at the Dolphin Club at Aquatic Park.
And she said, this is, I love the way she describes this.
She describes her, you know,
she says not many people have a visual record
of their rebirth.
And she said that they happen to like video her that day
when she got in the water and started swimming.
And she said like, you know,
here's this like broken, skinny,
like 120 pound woman who was just like,
has been through hell
and is like the biggest shit eating grin on her face.
And she's in this water and she feels so alive
and she feels, so,
she feels reborn.
Like it literally was her,
it started this completely new life for her,
you know, as a marathon swimmer,
as a freakishly accomplished marathon swimmer.
And I think a large part of that of course,
is that she is a very resilient person.
Yeah.
She also talks about how she has
a very very high pain threshold,
which has gotten to her into a lot of trouble,
you know, over the years.
Why?
Well, I mean the whole thing with her leg
when she fell down the stairs that day.
She kind of ignored it.
She ignored it
and she drove to work.
And then her leg was like twice the size.
And then she passed out and then she got to the hospital
and it was like, you know,
all that swelling was killing all the nerves in her leg
and they almost had to amputate her leg.
And so she laughs at it.
And again, of course then that pain tolerance
of course allows her also to do extraordinary things.
And she also had a bout with
a couple of bouts Guillen-Barre, you know.
That's more recent.
More recent, yeah.
How is she doing now?
She seems to be doing pretty well.
We talked recently,
a few weeks ago, a couple of weeks ago.
And you know, she's swimming.
You know, during the pandemic,
she's back in the Bay swimming.
And she's trying to knock out
the seven summits also, right?
Did that get tabled for the time being?
That was her big goal.
And it really was.
I mean, she was well on her way
when Guillen-Barre happened to her.
And I don't know if that's something
that's still on the table.
But she wanted to be the first person to do
both of those things.
Yeah, nobody's ever done that, have they?
Don't get any ideas, people. (laughing)
That's Kim's thing.
I'm not doing it.
But what's, you know, even additionally compelling about her
is not only her, you know, love for cold water.
Like she took to it immediately.
Her freakish endurance capacity,
but also this interesting relationship with fear
because she swam from the Farallon islands,
you know, to San Francisco.
The most
That is not for the
faint of heart.
shark infested.
She did it at night too where you can't see anything.
It sounds like my worst nightmare.
It's pretty much everybody's worst nightmare.
And she's like, ah, she thought it was fun, you know?
And a thing on top of all of this
that makes her, separates her, I think.
Right. The fear.
I mean, she'll be the first person to talk about
how she was afraid so many times about,
you know like people seeing her scars,
you know that's one thing.
Just that she had changed so much
from that person who fell down the stairs that day,
and then over the course of becoming this swimmer
and then, you know breaking these world records
then coming to this point where she wanted
to make these swims bigger than herself, right?
So then turning her attention
from her own struggles outward to say,
okay if I have a voice, what can I use this for?
And she did that Colibri swim.
The red sea thing?
No, well that one too
but the one across the border
Oh, right, in Mexico.
Yeah, to Tijuana.
And that, you know
she did that with a Mexican swimmer Antonio Arguelles.
And they were like the ambassadors, you know, across the,
and it was really to call attention
to all the deaths at the border.
She kept saying that it wasn't.
She didn't want it to be political.
She wanted it to be about life and caring about life.
And she said, when they swam across
and got out the beach in Tijuana,
all these school kids were on the cliff
wearing the Colibri t-shirts and cheering.
And she's like, it was this,
it was like wanting to use the swims
as a way to bring people together.
And I really,
I so admire her for all of the,
you know this evolution that she's gone through in her life.
I mean, she always talks about how,
and it's hard for me to imagine this
but she said she was a really shallow person
like before all of this.
Really?
Yeah.
You can't imagine it, right.
No.
She's like this
glowing light.
Yeah. Yeah.
But something got activated in her.
Something got activated,
yeah.
You know?
And in the Venn diagram of these various buckets
or categories that you've divided the book up into
you know, she overlaps, you know, survival with community.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, she is that bridge because,
you know, not just the healing part,
but the, you know, she survived so many things in her life
because of swimming.
And swimming was the thing that kind of brought her back
from both her leg injury and then from Guillen-Barre,
and was a way for her to rehab her life.
She really did do that.
But it was through this amazing community
at the Dolphin Club.
And I think about, I remember being
in the locker room there, the locker room,
and that's something that I super miss in this time,
like the locker room at the pool.
Right, the post swim.
Just like the chatting and the secrets
and you're in everybody's, you know, intimate space,
but I don't know what it's like in the men's locker room,
actually wanna ask you about this.
Because it's not, I mean, at least from my perspective,
it's like this, I think Kim has described
the Dolphin Club sauna as like a hen house.
Like everyone's just sharing like,
you know, stories of like illness
or boyfriend troubles or things
that they're struggling with.
I don't know what it's like on the other side.
Well, it's changed with different phases of life,
you know?
But I think the unifying principle is that
when you complete a swimming workout, you're kind of,
it's like this pipe cleaner for your mind
and your soul, right?
Like you emerge from that experience
like feeling very grounded and also open, right?
So then when you go to the like, you know,
like, listen, when I swam in college
everybody goes into the hot showers
and is in there forever, right?
You don't just quick take a quick shower and get dressed.
Like you stay in that hot shower as long as possible.
And there's a lot of, you know,
yeah, there's a lot of conversation that goes on there.
And even in masters swimming, it's the same.
For sure.
I mean, I don't know what the women's locker room is like
but like yeah, there's a lot of, you know, bonding
and I think it's different with men because men
you know, are,
it's harder to get men to, you know
have kind of intimate conversations
with their friends and their peers.
But there's something about that locker room experience
that's conducive to that
in the wake of just enduring
like a difficult workout together, you know.
And maybe it's the same in track and field
or any other sport, I don't know.
But it's certainly, you know
a tight knit bond that you have with those people
that you know, you do this hard thing together.
And even though it's individual
you are doing it as a collective.
Right, you're doing it.
You're doing it apart together.
Yeah.
Yeah, that makes it interesting.
Well, let's talk about the wellbeing component of this
because I think there's a lot of people listening
who either are swimmers or people
who are perhaps intrigued by the idea
of maybe getting into cold water for the first time,
or, you know, trying to learn how to swim
when they didn't learn as a kid.
There's so much wellbeing to be mined
from this sport or just this activity.
I mean, I also want to, you know, we talked a bit
about the physical and physiological benefits right?
Of immersion, but I also want to talk,
you know, a big part of the wellbeing is the flow, right?
It's the flow state.
It's where your mind goes
when you're doing it.
And I think, again, what's so interesting about swimming
and makes it unusual and unique in the sort of sports world
is that you are,
you're alone, you're in your head a lot.
Your senses are muted.
You're not really talking to someone else.
I mean, even if you're doing a workout together,
even if you're doing a long swim together with someone,
you know in the Bay or in the ocean or whatever,
you're not chatting the way you would,
if you were going for a long run together.
And so your awareness,
I mean, I think it depends on
okay, so I want to talk about two things
like pool swimming is super different
from open water swimming, right?
So in a pool what's so great about that
is that it's this very known circumscribed.
The distance is known,
your body knows where to do the turns.
And you know, your mind is freed
in a way that is different from open water,
because open water you're have a sort of acute nowness.
You need a little bit of hypervigilance in open water.
Yeah.
And even if you're someone like Lynn Cox or Kim Chambers,
and you're swimming for like a shit ton of time,
like just so long,
you are still attuned to what's going on
in your environment in a way that's like, again
you're attentive to dangers,
potential dangers although your crew is probably
supposed to be doing that.
But when you're out there, I mean, you're,
I find that when I'm swimming in the Bay
I'm constantly scanning, you know.
You can't really stop yourself from doing that
even if you know this place.
There's still some alert, you know?
And I think that then
the acuteness and the presentness
of being in the water is like, again,
like taking you out of your head
and all the shit that's going on outside of that.
Like, I think to be forced
to pay attention to that moment.
Right, you're just compelled to be
in the moment and present.
Yeah.
And you have for that hour or 45 minutes
or whatever, you have forgotten about just everything.
All of the things that are holding you down
are occupying, preoccupying you.
And you know, right now there's plenty of that.
But I mean, actually, I just realized
like in this conversation with you
the way a great conversation can take you out.
I haven't thought about COVID for a while.
So thank you for that.
Okay, I gave you a one hour reprieve from that.
I really appreciate that.
But I'm distracting you, right.
Yeah so that, you know, being an open water is a
I don't want to say distraction
because distraction sounds negative.
Like distraction sounds like,
it's not quite the right word
because it seems like it's something that you shouldn't be
focusing your attention on.
But it compels your focus in a way
that I think is super useful.
And again, it's a relief.
It's a breath away from the rest of everything.
Your normal state of being, your normal land self
and then in a pool it's, I find it no less.
I know a lot of people don't love swimming in pools
but I really love pools.
I do too.
And when people say it's boring,
I don't find it boring at all.
There's something about that constriction.
Like how can you stare at the black line the whole time?
But because you know exactly how long the pool is
and you know that your environment is static essentially,
And safe.
That gives you
the opportunity and safe, right.
That you don't have to think about it, right.
And it allows you to like live in this
state of presence, but also kind of the,
and you talk about this in the book as well,
like this liminal state, right.
Where you're not on land,
you're not underwater.
You're kind of in-between.
And there's something about that, that place.
It puts your mind in a place to problem solve
or to be in this active meditation state.
And that's very related to the breath, of course.
And you talk about that in the book as well.
Like the regulated, you know, inhaling and exhaling
that comes with that,
that, you know, has some impact
on your sympathetic nervous system
in a certain particular way.
You're allowed to wander.
I mean, you're allowed to make connections
and things are floating around.
They're not tethered in the same way.
I think that,
again, I come back to the quality of the medium.
Things don't have to be connected in the same way.
At least for me,
I have interrogated myself many times
over the writing of this book when I'm swimming.
Like, what the hell am I thinking about?
How am I thinking about these things?
You know, I wrote a great amount of the book
in my head when I was swimming.
I'm sure, yeah.
Well, I'm sure you get stuck.
Because I had to come back.
You go swim.
And then by, you know, not focusing on it,
you are allowed, you're able to free associate
and solve that problem
so that when you are you're in the locker room afterward,
you're like, (snapping) I got it.
I think that's the
I love that term, the soft fascination, right?
There's something that's holding our attention
but not too closely
so that you're able to
do that free association that you're talking about,
which is so great.
Yeah and it's, you know,
it's different from running.
Like running is analogous, I suppose.
But the experience isn't quite the same.
For some reason.
I mean, definitely not from me.
I don't know about you.
I hate running.
I mean I love running too.
But the feeling that I have afterwards is different.
It's different.
Certainly swimming makes me more tired
and definitely more hungry.
Oh, so hungry.
I know, why do you get so hungry?
And also talk to me about this.
When I, after a swim workout,
I have to pee like 400 times.
I can not stop peeing.
What is going on?
That doesn't happen to me running.
It's weird, right?
It's gotta be have
to do something about
There's some weird
physiological thing
like the hydrostatic
pressure.
that occurs.
Or something on your body that somehow
then you're like all the water gets forced out.
I literally have to go to the bathroom like
10 times over two hours.
If there's someone listening who knows why this happened,
please email us because
we want to know.
I think I tweeted
that question out one time.
And I got a bunch of answers.
It was a long time ago, but.
There is some biological reason.
I think part of it has to do with being horizontal.
Part of it has to do
with the temperature,
Oh, interesting.
Water, temperature.
You know, even when you're swimming in a 75 degree pool
it's still so much colder than your body.
So your body is expanding a large percentage
of its resources just to keep you warm
on top of, you know the exercise that you're doing.
Yeah.
I think that the tiredness and the hunger
and also it's like a delayed thing, right?
So you're not really thinking about,
I mean I don't really get hungry when I'm swimming usually
but then like, you know, sometimes I'll be in the shower
and I'll just be like,
holy shit give me a, I'm so hungry.
I know.
But I get freaked out open water swimming.
Do you?
Well, I don't,
I don't mind it in tropical locations
where I can see everything,
but in the Pacific it's so murky.
And I don't like not being able to see the bottom.
And then your mind starts to wander too.
In a bad way.
You know, you're a part of this food chain,
you're unbelievably vulnerable.
And then it's difficult for me to like, relax and enjoy it.
Well part of that is definitely the temperature.
Do you have particular moments that you recall
as being super terrifying in open water?
I mean, I will say
that when I'm with other people it's fine,
but sometimes I want to just go by myself
but I'm reluctant to do that.
I just don't feel like that's a responsible thing to do.
So I've done it, but then I'm nervous
because I'm alone and no one quite knows where I am.
Right, yeah.
One of the things about open water swimming
in the time of COVID was I kept telling myself
that you have to be more conservative
than you might be otherwise
because you don't want anyone to have to save you.
And I got freaked out
when I did the Alcatraz swim,
this was a very long time ago.
My buddies and I did it without a wetsuit.
Cause we were, you know, 25 or whatever.
And it's like your a puss if you wear a wetsuit.
So we did it without wetsuits.
And I just remember being halfway.
I mean, it's not that far, what is it
like a kilometer and a half or something like that?
It's like, what is it,
a mile and a half?
A mile and a half maybe?
Yeah.
Being in the middle,
like perhaps like smack in the middle.
And I just stopped for a moment
and looked around and I was like, I'm in a shipping channel.
Like that freaked me out
cause there's massive
boats out there.
Oh, they come
and they're on you
in a second.
And so it wasn't the
marine life,
it was like the fact that like there's gigantic
cargo ships that pass through there.
But my hands and my feet got so numb.
They just felt like nubs.
You're like doing this. (laughing)
The fist swimming.
I didn't do that again without a wetsuit.
I had a similar experience
when I was doing my Alcatraz swim.
And then I hit a patch of seaweed.
And you know when you hit something when you're swimming,
you can't stop yourself from doing that jerk upright.
And it was like my heart was like
in my mouth and then I just was like,
Oh, sea weed, sea weed, sea weed.
Cause you just, you're right.
You can't see anything.
Yeah, it's freaky.
And something touches you.
(laughing)
I'm not really afraid of sharks.
Like if I'm in Hawaii and I can see everything
even if I saw a predatory fish,
like I don't know that it would scare me that much.
Recently, I've been working
for the last couple of months on a story about fear
and that involves a shark,
involved sharks and someone
who spends a lot of time with them.
And I was thinking to myself that I have never,
sharks haven't been a thing for me either, right.
It's not something that has occupied my mind
but I also have been really intrigued
by how it occupies the imagination
of so many people who would never encounter sharks.
But it lives in their imagination and of course Jaws,
but also that
it's like a convenient receptacle for your fear.
Right.
Right, it personifies whatever fear that you have.
Yeah.
And actually, it just is a way for you to
deal with it.
Like it's all of these other things.
And when we were just talking earlier about the, you know
being in the dark deep ocean and the sharks,
like that being the most profound fear
or the scariest place in anyone.
Like a primal thing
that we have inside of us.
And it is, yeah.
Do you know this guy, Michael Mueller, this photographer
who's done all these
photo essays on great whites
and he swims outside of the cage.
And it's incredible.
He's always on the podcast.
And now he's creating this virtual reality.
Oh, really?
Series where you put on the goggles and you know
basically you're swimming with great whites
outside of a cage.
Have you tried it?
He let me test it in the middle of the podcast.
We took a break and I put them on and checked it out.
It's wild, right?
But they're using this now in kind of a
Oh, like a kind of fear conditioning.
Yeah.
Exactly, yeah.
Yeah, to work with people who have PTSD
and other kinds of fears
to help help them like process all of that in a healthy way.
Yeah I think that that fear exposure
or exposure therapy is really interesting.
And I think it's fascinating how VR can help with that.
And I'm really curious about how the technology,
you know cause so much of the earlier iterations of it
have made people so nauseous.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think they're still working that out.
It got a little bit like that.
I think I would have then developed
a fear of nausea. (laughing)
I don't know how you could possibly solve
for that problem though, because your body,
your inner ear is just doing whatever it's,
I don't think that you, how do you correct that?
You know, how do you
I don't know.
Solve the disconnect, I mean?
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know the answer to that.
You can ask him.
I should talk to Michael.
Yeah, I'll hook you up.
You should interview him.
When you look at Kim
or people like Lynn Cox or Louis Pugh or Martin Strauss
like these epic, you know, super long distance swimmers.
Louis like swam in the Arctic circle, right?
Unreal.
And didn't Martin swim the Amazon?
He swam the Amazon.
He did like a ridiculous amount
of butterfly too, didn't he?
Yes, which I think is hilarious.
I'm like, how is that?
He's like he swam the whole Amazon river butterfly.
I'm like, that's not humanly possible.
I don't know what kind
He seems like
a kooky guy.
of butterfly he's doing.
I'm like, it can't be the butterfly that-
What's your form like?
Yeah, I would like to see that.
It's still crazy impressive, I can't imagine.
But like, what is it that these people share?
Definitely a high pain threshold.
What I have gleaned from talking to
some of these incredible endurance swimmers
is that they are different.
They're definitely different from us.
Or maybe not from you.
You're an endurance athlete.
I don't like cold though.
I'm like go ahead.
I think cold is a divisive thing
amongst us humans.
I like it after I've done it.
And I've put myself
in that situation
But then you don't run
towards it.
for that reason.
But I'm not like Kim who like
can't wait to get into
the cold water.
Yes, right.
She just jumps right in.
There's like a certain single-mindedness I think.
And certainly an ability to,
I think disassociate from their bodies and in a lot of ways
because their bodies are enduring so much
not just with the cold, but with the length of time
and the distance that they're swimming.
But they seem like they have all kinds
of different reasons for,
that they say.
Right, well, Louis it's very much
about environmental preservation.
Like he has a big why, you know,
a big purpose behind why he does what he does.
But he also talked about how before he started doing that
I think he was a lawyer.
Wasn't he a lawyer?
I think so.
And then just started.
Yeah, I think that he so wanted to swim.
He kind of developed the reasons to swim
over the course of time, but he was a very driven person.
So like, I think that
these athletes are,
do start out as very motivated people,
whatever it is they're doing.
Kim was super motivated, like doing her
you know, and her, you know, Silicon Valley job before.
Right, Adobe, I think.
So I think that they have just turned their focus
and vision to something that they can really go all in on
in a practice that rewards that.
Right?
And it is very extreme.
I think I'm having trouble talking about it
because I don't understand it myself.
You know, even in the competition part of the book.
And actually this is interesting.
I asked Lynn Cox and I asked Lewis Pugh
about competition, right.
And Lynn really chafed against me asking her that question
because she said, I'm not competitive.
I'm not swimming against anyone else.
And then it kind of asks you to-
You can still be internally competitive.
Exactly.
And then actually while she kept talking,
she chafed against it because she didn't see it as,
she didn't see it as being externally motivated
by what anyone else was doing.
I think that was the thing that she,
that rubbed her the wrong way to think about.
She is concerned with it though.
Like it was about being the first
and the coldest and the longest.
But it was against herself for sure.
I think that,
because once she started talking about it, it became this,
it was clear that she is a competitive person
even though she didn't necessarily like to think
of herself that way.
Well, with Kim,
it all seems so easy.
Like, cause she's always laughing and smiling, you know,
like ain't nothing but a thing.
Oh but she is like, she's got some shark in her.
Yeah, I know.
Did you talk to Ross Edgley?
I didn't talk to Ross Edgely.
Ross Edgley, I remember.
God, I remember when he did,
what was the last?
It was a year and a half ago I think
when he did the great British swim.
The book was done.
But I remember reading about that
and thinking he would have been an interesting guy
and he has his own book.
He's great.
I mean he's also a force of positive energy.
Like he just,
he's insanely fit and like trains like a madman,
but he's always laughing.
Like it is play.
I mean, this is another theme of the book
like the relationship between swimming and play.
And Kim has that.
Ross definitely has that.
Like, he's a beast,
but he's literally constantly cracking jokes
and just, you know, lighting up whatever room
that he walks into.
He's very charismatic in that regard.
And what's interesting about him is he looks
like a bodybuilder, but he has unbelievable endurance.
So he wrote this book about, you know,
this combination of endurance and strength
and how that works.
Cause you would think like,
oh, you gotta be really lean
to be able to do something so long,
but he swam all the way around Great Britain.
It was bananas.
He documented the whole thing along the way.
Like he had the rashes on his neck from his wetsuit
I remember reading about that.
Yeah he just got like open,
Like gaping wound, like on week one,
you know, when he's doing this.
And he came out into the podcast like right afterwards
like he literally had just,
Did you see his scars?
Did he show you?
I see he's got
a massive scar.
He was putting, you know, that heavy
heavy duct tape on it and all kinds of stuff.
But he's somebody who,
you know, grew up as a water polo player,
was kind of a competitive swimmer
but not at an elite level or anything like that.
And just comes up with these events to do
so he's internally competitive.
He's competitive with himself
and he's battling the elements,
but it's not about,
there's never anyone else that he's competing against
other than himself,
and the elements.
Yeah, I think that you,
to do all of these things,
you have to have some motivation that is
just very consuming, you know.
Whether it's externally motivated or internally,
it's just, it is.
And I think that
because you've had conversations with all kinds of people
who are pushed to do extraordinary things,
I'm sure that the sort of like outset,
you know, what, you know whether it's something
that they were always striving for approval from someone
or that they always just wanted to
know that they were capable of something more
than what everyone told them that they could do,
or whether it's for some, you know,
I want to raise awareness about something.
How do we talk about it is important.
I suppose that it's not necessarily,
it doesn't necessarily matter
what the specific thing is,
but there's gotta be some force
that is compelling us to do it.
Right.
I loved the backtracking into the history of swimming
and in particular, competitive swimming,
tracing it back to its roots
all the way to Ben Franklin inventing the hand paddles,
which was like that blew my mind.
I can't stop thinking about that.
I mean, he is the true Renaissance man.
Of course he invented hand paddles.
You know, it's unbelievable.
And that cave in the Sahara
where it was basically a tomb, right,
where there were drawings of people swimming in a pond
when at one time, very long ago
the Sahara was a lush,
Green,
the green Sahara.
Green area.
It wasn't the desert.
It was dotted with paleo lakes, you know.
I love that story.
I love that, you know, the first human record of swimming
is in the middle of the desert in Africa.
Because of course it is.
But that you look at these images
and it really looks like people are just breaststroke,
breast stroking up the walls.
And I also love that
the Hungarian explorer who discovered that cave
at the time was almost, he wrote a book about it.
And he speculated that
there were actual lakes and bodies of water
around the cave at the time that the drawings were made.
And of course the theory of climate change then
was just outrageous and so radical.
And he was like
his editor reportedly was so like, upset about that,
that he put a footnote that said
I don't subscribe to this like harebrained idea of,
That at one time there was water
in the middle of the Sahara.
Of course there was.
But of course he was right.
Yeah.
But at that time it was pretty radical.
And now of course, there's so much evidence
about the green Sahara and that there are,
you know hippo bones, tortoise shells,
like fish, you know,
mittens of clam shells.
Like it's just amazing to think about it.
Yeah, it's crazy.
And to think that human's relationship
with water dates back to the inception of mankind.
And certainly before any wreck,
you know, this is probably dates back up to 10,000 years ago
but we likely knew how to swim way before that.
It's just that there's no trace of it.
No evidence, yeah.
Let's talk about the samurais,
the martial arts of swimming.
This is something else I had no idea about
which is super cool.
So there is,
of course there is a swimming martial art in Japan.
So Nihon Eiho is the term for it in Japanese.
It's the Japanese classical swimming art.
So much like Judo or Kendo, there's the practice.
And it originated with the samurai
during the feudal period of Japan
and think about all these parcels of land
that had to be protected by these different samurai clans.
And because of Japan being archipelago
and there's different, you know,
there could be on the ocean
or it could be on the edge of a lake or a river,
the clans each develop their own schools of swimming.
So they had different techniques for how to protect
their, you know, the, the land that they were protecting.
And there are these, one of my favorite tidbits is
that the sort of egg beater technique
of synchronized swimming
has been described in samurai scrolls,
like hundreds of years old.
And if you think about some of the things that they taught
in these schools of swimming,
they're called Ryu.
I'm not pronouncing it right, R-Y-U.
That, you know, you would learn how to cut
through breaking waves with your arms,
like in a parallel fashion,
or that you would learn to approach in a very calm lake,
you know, submerged,
like most of your body's submerged.
And you would learn to leap up out of the water into a boat.
There's a move called the Flying Mullet.
You can also go Google this.
The Flying Mullet?
Yeah, on YouTube.
But this is from a warrior culture.
This is from a warrior culture.
You use water to your advantage.
Exactly.
So it is much in the same way that now martial arts
you know, they are a practice, right.
They are a physical, but also a psychological practice,
a philosophical practice, a whole body practice and mind.
And I love, I loved learning about Nihon Eiho
because it was a different way to think about swimming
outside of this Western idea of competition and racing.
And it is fascinating because,
you know, Nihon Eiho is still practiced in Japan today.
And I went to Japan to research this
and you know in the Tokyo Olympics,
they were supposed to have an exhibition of.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
I spoke with a lot of these masters
of different schools of Nihon Eiho
who were preparing this exhibition
to kind of reintroduce to the world
and perhaps introduce for the first time
what the sort of foundation of
Japanese swimming, you know,
the national team success that we know it today.
So much of it breaststroke, right?
So they've been, Japanese members have been really dominant
in breaststroke for a long time.
And there's an interesting historical link
to the techniques of Nihon Eiho.
I mean, I remember talking to
one of these masters of the art
and he was trying to explain it.
And we were observing a class in Yokohama
of these swimmers taking the class.
And he said, you know,
we were observing the glide
and the certain formations that they would be swimming in.
And he said, you know, Kitajima,
you know Kosuke Kitajima, which is like,
The world record holder, 100 meter breastroke, right?
Just this dominant breaststroker
known for like this incredible glide.
And he said, that's Nihon Eiho.
Like, he was just like, that's the skill that we teach.
And that has been ingrained into like coaching.
Yeah.
it's fascinating to track that,
you know the antecedent of Japanese swimming success
back to that practice.
And I didn't know that the Japanese were so dominant
at the end of the 1920s,
like the 1934 Olympics they won like 12 medals
or something like that.
I had no idea that,
They like blasted
onto the scene.
They were crushing it
back then.
That was crazy.
And it's all rooted in this practice
which my sense is
it's not quite a Tai Chi thing
but maybe where they might share some sensibility
is this idea of
learning how to use,
learning how to work with the water,
like being symbiotic with the water
and using it to your advantage.
Like, we all know the swimmer who isn't so experienced
and they're in a race
or in a triathlon or something like that.
And they're fighting the water.
They're fighting, it's obvious.
They're making the water work against them.
You know what I mean?
And really, you know swimming is about fitness of course,
and technique but it's really about finesse.
It's this delicate relationship
and this touch and this feel
that you develop over time
and some have an innate talent for
where they just know how to flow with the water
and make it work for them.
And those tend to be the most successful swimmers.
I think that the Tai Chi analogy
is really salient in this context.
I mean, it is about working with the element
and figuring out how to
use it to your advantage
and be really efficient too.
I think that's something that
people don't really think about with swimming.
And they think that it's like you said,
when people are starting to swim
or starting to learn how to swim competitively and go fast,
like there's so much muscling,
there's so much over,
like, windmilling, you know.
You're just trying to like overpower it with brute force.
And really it's about like,
your timing, your angle of entry,
the position of your body in the water.
And if you have that, it's actually quite,
you're not expending a lot of energy.
One of the things that's interesting about Lynn Cox
is that her buoyancy is such that
in salt water, she's like neutrally buoyant.
So she's in that perfect
body position to be swimming
for hours and hours and hours
and miles and miles and miles
because she has that.
She's riding a little bit higher
than your average person would.
You know, and she's talked about that.
So that also helps her, you know
with her very, very long swims.
But it's also about touch and finesse, like you said.
For sure.
And in this practice, they have much like karate
like you get lines on your cap or whatever.
Yeah.
Each like level that you achieve.
I think it was like stripes in some cases.
Cause I asked them, I said how do you know who's the master?
And they said, look at the caps.
And they all have their special caps.
And it was so cool to learn about it.
And I hope to get the opportunity,
I actually had been trying and planning to get
to the Tokyo Olympics so I could see that, you know, happen.
See that sort of re-introduction
of Nihon Eiho to the world.
What's your sense of
whether the Olympics are going to happen or not?
Oh my gosh, well,
can they make a bubble big enough?
I don't know.
Right, what do you think?
I don't know, I don't know.
I don't know.
It's changing so quickly.
I mean, the spikes that we're seeing right now
make me feel pessimistic about it,
but we'll have to see.
But at some point they have to make a decision.
There's so many moving pieces and so much money at stake.
They can't just snap their fingers right beforehand
and say it's happening or it's not.
Like at what point do you pass that point of no return
in terms of the green light or the red light?
Well, now we're getting,
and then we'll be getting to the point where then
it isn't the same year as the winter Olympic year, right?
Again, which is kind of ironic.
I know.
Can you imagine being an Olympic athlete
and living in that space of not knowing?
Yeah, it's like a state of suspended animation
and I think it's so,
I so feel for those athletes who are
not knowing, you know they're training
and then they have had to calibrate their training
for another year.
And then I think it will like break a lot of people
if it doesn't happen.
I mean it'll play to the advantage
of the younger less experienced athlete, I suppose
who benefits with additional time
but there's so many people that are hanging on
and trying to make ends meet while they do it.
And without that certainty
it's probably really difficult to get sponsor support.
Like it's just gotta be really challenging.
It turns out it's expensive to be an athlete.
It is, right?
It's expensive to live.
Another idea that I really love about the book
is this idea that to be a swimmer
is to be a seeker on some level.
And when you track through history
there are so many leaders and great thinkers
who had this profound relationship with the water.
From the row to Lord Byron
and, you know, even JFK,
like people who would gravitate towards the water
in times of crisis or as a daily practice
to basically help them be more self-actualized,
better human beings.
Right.
I love that FDR was the one who put the pool in.
You know, FDR put the pool in the white house
and it lives under the white house press pool briefing room
which is just,
Is that why it's called the press pool?
I don't actually know.
I've never quite been able to pinpoint if that's why.
But I recently had,
yeah, I recently was talking about this with someone
and you know, one of the reporters at NPR
who reports in the white house said,
yes, you can see the tile.
So you'd be in the room.
So it's underneath the room,
but you can still see the tile
and like where the pool actually
is a bunch of like internet servers and stuff. (laughing)
And I thought that is,
oh, and that Hillary Clinton wanted
when they moved into the white house,
she wanted to reopen the pool again as a pool.
Somehow that didn't happen.
But I thought, wow, that would have been great.
Right.
Well, I know JFK swam a lot.
And in particular it was very helpful
when he was in the middle of the Cuban missile crisis
to try to like get some distance and balance.
So he could solve this unsolvable problems.
Isn't it fun to think about swimming
as like a a hidden actor in these moments of history, maybe?
That's a good one.
Well and imagine being FDR, the freedom, you know
of being able to get out of the wheelchair
and move your body.
Well and that he hid his,
Yeah, nobody knew.
Yeah, he hid his, it was so hard.
And then it finally became, you know
impossible to hide
his physical, you know, limitations.
Right.
So how do you think about that relationship
between being a seeker and being in the water?
I mean, I certainly think it's true for myself.
I wrote my first book, American Chinatown
about how I noticed that when I would go to a city,
the first thing I do, I look to see
if they had a Chinatown and I would go
and kind of see, it was just interesting.
It was just a little window to see
how is this place different or the same to me
across the Chinese diaspora.
And then I realized what I do with swimming
is that I look for a place
to swim.
The pool, yeah.
A pool or a body of water.
How often is the pool in Chinatown?
Oh, well there's the Chinatown YMCA
in San Francisco, there you go.
Gorgeous pool.
But yeah, not that often, (laughing) it turns out.
But I don't know.
I think that water, I think water
and seeking it is something that,
for me it's about finding freedom.
It's about finding a new perspective.
It's about finding a new way of looking at things.
And I mean, isn't that what being a writer is?
So I think for me, it's like these two things
are hand-in-hand for sure
about how my mind works that way.
What's the longest you've gone without swimming?
Oh, that's a great question.
Even when I tore my ACL (laughing) many, many years ago,
oh God, I remember this.
I had that stupid machine
that like moves your knee at night.
And my husband made me sleep on the couch
because I was like, I'm not sleeping next to that thing.
Oh God, that was like, what?
15 years ago?
I wasn't out of the water for that long,
but it's because it's rehab, it's recovery.
It's like one of the first like the only things you could do
when you're, you know recovering from surgery in many cases.
Right.
It's interesting that when people get injured on land
they send them to the pool to repair themselves.
And then they go back on land.
And then pound the crap out of their bodies.
Yeah I had Laird Hamilton here the other day
and he's got these legendary pool workouts, you know.
And part of the philosophy behind it is that very thing
which is when you injure yourself
and you go to physio
they teach you all these rudimentary like things
and you kind of do them for a while and then you're healed
and then you stopped doing them.
And he's like, we should just keep doing them.
And what if we do some of the more rigorous exercises
in the pool where you remove the thing
that's making you injured in the first place
and create the supportive environment
that allows you to do more with less risk?
Laird Hamilton is basically saying
what every physical therapist is like yelling
at their patient and saying, just keep doing it.
Why don't you keep doing it?
My brother's a PT.
So I hear him lamenting all the time.
And he says to me, cause I said my elbow and my shoulder
were sort of bothering me the other day, he said
"So did you stop doing the exercises that I gave you?"
And I said "Yes."
Of course I did.
I could go back and swim.
So that was in the past.
So then I stopped of course.
Let's talk about this guy in Iraq,
Iraq, who was teaching swimming lessons
because this is another cool story.
I didn't know anything about this guy,
like the foreign service dude.
Jay Taylor, this is another story.
Actually, this section of the book came.
He was also another pen pal of mine
but he was a pen pal, like many, like a long time ago.
He had read something that I had written
for the New York Times about swimming
as the last refuge from connectivity.
And he said, you know
I have a story for you about how it brought people together.
And it was about community, about connection.
And he was this foreign service guy
who got sent to Iraq for a posting for a couple of years.
I think it was 2008 to 2010.
And it was a time when Baghdad was seeing
a lot of like shelling activity.
And so it was a pretty hairy time to be there.
And he was in the green zone
which at the time was part, was in situated in
Saddam Hussein's Republican palace.
Now, I don't know if you know this
but Saddam Hussein and his sons were very fond of swimming.
And so at all of their palaces
and homes around Iraq, they had these crazy pools.
Like just again, like luxury upon luxury in the desert
is like having a pool that you keep filled.
And this pool had multilevel diving boards.
In fact, you can see, there are some,
I don't know if they're still up
but there are some YouTube videos of service,
Soldiers swimming, yeah.
Soldiers like jumping off of the diving boards,
which doesn't actually, it doesn't,
see, watching them doesn't speak well of us.
I don't know.
There's just something so-
Well, we just, we descend upon the palace
and take it over, and turn it into like a playground.
It's that kind of like imperialist view
that has so gotten us into trouble.
But anyway, so,
but in this time of war, of course
there is a community that forms around this pool because
of course, everyone is drawn to this oasis.
Yeah who wouldn't wanna be at that pool?
Yeah and suddenly they're like, wait
we're allowed to use this pool?
It is like got fountains and tiles and diving boards.
And it just is glorious.
And again, it's peace, it's finding quiet.
And he said that when he
would get in this pool
he would just, then that's when he stopped hearing
like the firing range.
Like you know, you'd be muffled.
And otherwise it's like this incessant noise
of like military exercises.
And, you know, there the people who were there
were from all over the world, you know
they're diplomats, soldiers, UN peacekeepers, translators,
local Iraqis, who were, you know, there providing support.
And he saw that that pool was again
like everyone, all the animals flocked
to the watering hole, right?
But this, in this case it was like a psychological space.
Like a coping mechanism.
A coping mechanism.
And he was swimming.
He taught swimming lessons for a long time.
He was a lifeguard, you know
had grown up in the Baltimore suburbs, I think DC.
And he has, you know great form
and he started to teach.
A lot of people would come up to him, and say
"Hey, you got any tips for me?"
And he would see his colleagues flailing around in the pool
and he would offer some tips.
And he's a very, like when you read the book,
you understand that he's just like a very kind,
he's a teacher.
His joy and his role in life is to be a teacher.
And you've encountered many coaches over your life
as have I.
And the best coach is one who
kind of instills a little bit of fear. (laughing)
But that you want, it's authority.
You seek that approval though.
You seek that approval.
I wouldn't say that he's a person.
Oh, I don't know what, what he is like as a parent
but he's a very gentle guy at this point in his life.
But you see that he has this quiet authority
that you want to, you know that he knows things
and you want him to share them with you.
And so he was able to kind of,
I mean I think of him as a pied piper
of all of these swimmers
in the green zone, because he kind of was.
He ended up building this, you know, Baghdad swim club
of like a roster of 250,
some odd people rotated over two years
and would be teaching swimming lessons.
I mean, they kept having to add classes
because they kept coming to inquire.
It's like a feel good movie.
Yeah it's totally a feel good movie.
Jay Taylor folks.
You can contact me for the rights with him. (laughing)
I didn't realize what really struck me
aside from that story is this discussion around,
you know how beautiful the sunsets are
and like how people would swim,
like sort of at dusk or dawn,
like not at high noon, it was too hot.
But when the sand would kick up
that's when you would get the really epic sunsets.
But that was also the danger signal
because that's when the incoming mortars
would occur, right?
Because that sand would obscure
the ability to find the people who'd been hit.
Right.
Right, it was cover for,
it was a good mortaring opportunity.
And it's just like to exist in that reality.
Like, you're in this,
you have this pool with fountains
but right outside of it, like people are getting shelled.
Yeah.
And, you know
Jay almost got hit by a mortar in his trailer.
Like on the third day he was in Baghdad.
He really almost didn't live to
have this club, you know teach these people to swim.
And it sort of underlines this
just how, again porousness between states.
And that's one of the big themes of the book is like
where I think with swimming,
what's so intriguing to me about it is that it is a sport,
it is a practice.
It is something we do for exercise,
but it is,
it is the difference between life and death and water.
That is the reality.
I mean, that is crazy.
And we don't dance very often.
It's that close these days to death.
I mean, last year, this past year
has been an exceptional year to that.
But in our modern day we don't experience
that acute acuteness.
Most of us don't anyway,
most of us are lucky not to.
And so I think sports of course,
competition is a way to experience
this acuteness of being, right.
The adrenaline rush,
the urgency of feeling just really alive.
And, and oftentimes that,
you know, that feeling
is something that we kind of can only really approximate
with something that's a very heightened experience.
Right.
But swimming allows you to practice
literally putting yourself in an unnatural environment.
Yeah.
One that can really, again,
certainly, especially with the ocean
can really rob you of that life in pretty short order
if you're not careful. (laughing)
I don't want to scare people.
No.
I don't think about that.
Like I, you know, that doesn't occur.
I'm so acclimated to swimming, like
pool, forget about it.
Like, I don't think about a pool being dangerous at all.
Like, it's just, that is my natural habitat.
I'm more hyper aware of that
when I'm in the ocean, of course.
Right, but you were talking about
how you don't like it.
Yeah I know.
I mean, that's definitely a thing, but
but like in the pool, like the idea
that something bad is gonna happen to me
is not anything that I think about.
But that is a very real thing for a lot of people.
Right.
I mean, and I think that's super interesting.
And I wanted this book
to explore that with that reader.
I wanted to acknowledge that reality
that that fear is real.
Like, so the people who don't like swimming,
who are afraid of the water, that is very,
that is a profound fear.
And that is something that once you get to,
you know to become an adult, to be a certain age where
you feel that that door is completely closed to you
because that fear is so profound
and it's so primal,
and it is something that
you have to be fucking brave to actually push past that
and say I want to learn how to swim.
And I've talked to quite a few folks who,
you know had recently started to take lessons
or had started to
try to address their, you know,
their fears and their lack of swimming ability
over the course of the last couple of years.
And it's, you know, it is very much tied to
like some bad experiences they've had maybe
when they were kids,
but also there's just a lot of,
there's a lot of baggage there.
Well, you're very vulnerable.
You're essentially naked, you know
and you're putting yourself in this environment
where you can't breathe.
Your whole life you've like said talk to the hand, you know?
So it is courageous.
It's doable, if you submit to the process, you know.
it is a weird thing.
It's like violin or, you know, anything else
like if you don't learn it when you're a young kid
it's a lot harder when you're older
but that doesn't mean that you can't do it.
And I know plenty of people who learned later in life
and just love it now.
And it does serve,
you know, everybody has their own relationship with it.
I know that your relationship with it has changed over time
as has mine
but what will always remain consistent is this,
you know , flow like experience that you have
in water that I can't replicate in any other way.
You cite like Moby Dick in that, right?
Like this idea of sea dreaming,
like meditation and water are wedded forever,
which is a line out of that book.
Yeah.
Keeps me going.
It is meditation.
It is and it isn't,
it's a specific type of meditation.
It's moving meditation.
Actually someone had told me recently
that they stopped doing yoga once they discovered swimming.
Really?
Because it did
for them.
Serve that
function for them.
Yeah.
Yeah I'm not surprised
but you know what, it's better when you do both.
They're different, you know?
They're different.
And surfing is a whole different thing, right?
Which is another aspect of swimming,
I suppose on some level,
but it's own unique relationship with water
and symbiotically living
with the elements.
Yes.
And timing.
I mean, I thought about that this morning
and when I got out was just, you have to,
it's the same principle of you have to time it right.
You have to read the water right.
And then you have to move in just the right way
to get on the wave.
Otherwise it's not pretty.
Yeah.
So I suppose you're going to swim for the rest of your life.
I hope so.
They better open the pools back up soon.
Yeah, yeah.
Right?
I know a lot of mer-people out of water these days,
they just, they're not the same.
Don't you feel more just,
I feel like when I get in water in the morning,
I'm just a better person.
I just feel like it's all smoothed back.
But way better, I'm way more capable.
And when I said they better open the pools soon
let me please like couch that in context.
Like, I'm not saying be unsafe.
I just wish we could be in a situation
where it was, where pools could safely open.
Because I know that I'm a better person and I enjoy it.
And I miss it.
I know you do too.
What do you, let's close it with this thought, which is
what is it that you want people to walk away from
after reading the book?
I think it's a sense of possibility, right?
I just think about water these days.
And I've given this a lot of thought lately,
especially because I can't do it.
I can't do it as readily as I once could
and I took it for granted too, like anyone else, right.
That I could get in the water whenever I wanted to
and find that peace, find that,
you know, smoothing back of feathers
and that time with myself.
And now it's like this juggling act of trying to find
again like the lane reservation or the window
where like I know how to manage all,
you know, stuff at home with my kids and work and whatever.
And my husband
who only supports me, by the way, getting out in the water,
he's just like, go.
Please go.
Please go, we'll all be happier.
Does he swim?
He is, he's a pretty good swimmer.
He enjoys the water.
He hates the cold.
He's like you.
He will not get in the cold water.
I mean, when we woke up the other morning and it was,
it was like, you know, one of those mornings
that where you could see your breath.
And that's not that usual here in California guys,
as in many places.
This time of year though.
I mean, it's high 30s at night here
but then it'll be 82 by like two in the afternoon.
So he got up and it was before dark
and I was getting up to go surf
and he looks at him and he goes, boy,
what I really wanted to do right now is jump
in the freezing ocean!
(both laughing)
I just had to laugh because I said,
"You know, that actually, I mean I know it sounds insane,
but it sounds pretty good to me.
And that's why I'm leaving.
I love you, goodbye."
That's hilarious.
And so he understands me for sure.
It took me a long time to come back
to that kind of appreciation though
because I was so steeped in competitive swimming for so long
and the idea of the early morning alarm clock,
you know and then standing on the freezing cold deck
in the dark.
And I was like, I do not need this in my life anymore.
I did that for many years, you know
but I've kind of come around to,
you know, fall in love with it in a new way
as long as I don't look at the pace clock.
Cause that will give you PTSD.
That is going to do it.
Yeah I think it is interesting.
And I love to hear you talk about how
you had to come around full circle from
what was a very intense
and formative experience in your life,
you know, which is to compete at a collegiate level
in a very competitive school.
And very gratifying, and one of the highlights of my life,
but also extremely difficult
and not without its traumas, you know,
and like I needed to do other things.
So there was a long period of time
where I didn't want anything to do with the swimming pool.
Yeah, I mean, you have to have enough distance from it.
And also to understand that
yeah, like you're at a different stage of your life.
And I think, you know,
I like to think about how I came back to swimming as well.
Like there were times when it wasn't as present in my life
and now it's kinda come roaring back
in a very wonderful and real way.
Do you have a sense that you're more creative
when you're swimming consistently?
Like you're more in touch with your creative voice?
I think so.
And again, like, it was not something that I thought about
until I wrote this book.
Like I did not, you know,
examine or interrogate why
I wanted to get in the water
and then would go and sit and write.
But unconsciously you were,
you would not have been compelled to write the book, right?
Or been interested in exploring that.
It kinda nudged me that way.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Well, thank you.
Thank you.
For talking to me today.
I love the book.
Please go check it out.
It's called "Why We Swim."
It's a very direct title.
It answers that question.
I really loved it.
And I'm so happy that the book is being so well received
and so successful.
I know you've got another book, right?
It's like a children's book about a woman, big wave surfer?
It's "Sarah and the Big Wave."
And it's about Sarah Gerhardt,
the first woman who surfed Mavericks.
Yeah.
Is she the one that's in "Riding Giants?"
I don't know.
In the Mavericks segment?
Oh she probably was.
There's one woman that's interviewed
around the Maverick's discussion in that movie.
I mean it's been so long
since I've seen that documentary,
but yeah, it was
I mean she, 1999 and she's in,
she lives in Santa Cruz.
She's a, you know, she's a professor.
It's a wonderful story.
And it was my first children's book
and it was such a joy to write.
How did you find, like,
I assume you got an illustrator to work with?
Mhmm.
Sophie Diao.
They asked, my publisher actually asked me
like they don't normally do it.
So in publishing, I only just found this out
when I encountered this.
Usually, children's books,
you think that the, you know,
the writer and the and the illustrator's working together?
No.
It's like usually the writer writes the book
and then they find an illustrator and pair it.
Really?
Yeah, right?
No way.
Cause it's all these books seem so,
How is that possible?
Like you have to be sympatico.
Yeah, exactly.
And usually the publisher does not consult the author.
The publisher just chooses.
But in this case
No way.
They let me choose.
And she said, yes.
They don't consult the author
and they go and get some illustrator?
It's two lanes.
It's like, and they have the author
and they have illustrator
and they do the pairing.
That's like 90% of the time.
Isn't that fascinating?
That's shocking to me.
I know.
cause it seems like you have
It doesn't seem like
that'd work.
to have it braided together.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I mean, I guess it works. (laughing)
But I feel like they're missing out on an opportunity
is what I'm saying.
Yeah, I think so.
Speaking of which, why didn't you read your audio book?
Oh, that's a great question.
I don't know that the option was offered to me
but they said,
Should have just said I'm doing it.
They asked me, well again they asked me who I wanted.
So they gave me a bunch of different professionals.
Maybe they just thought they needed a professional.
But I thought Angie Cane.
She did a great job.
But I just think,
because you're so much a part of the narrative
that I would've,
I would've liked to have heard you read it.
Well thank you, next time.
Next time.
Put your foot down!
It's your book.
Now I'll just throw my weight around all the time.
Cool.
Well, come back and talk to me again some time.
This was really fun.
I would love to.
Thank you, Rich.
I appreciate it.
Where should I direct people who want to learn more
about what you're up to?
What's the best place?
You're on Twitter and all the things.
I'm on Twitter and Instagram and all the things.
You can find me on my website
at BonnieTsui.com.
Easiest way to do it.
Do it.
Alright, thanks.
Thanks.
Good, let's go swimming.
Let's do it. (laughing)
Peace, plants.